MALE SPEAKER: Really great
to welcome Chris to Google.
So this is Christopher Jones.
And he is an assistant professor
in the school of Philosophical
and Religious Studies at
Arizona State University.
He received his BA from
Stanford and his Ph.D.
from the University
of Pennsylvania.
He holds a
postdoctoral fellowship
at Harvard and UC Berkeley.
I think it's really exciting
to welcome Chris today,
because as Google gets
increasingly involved
in funding and providing
alternative energy resources,
and thinking deeply about
web and energy access
across the world, it's
important to understand
the market for
these technologies
as well as the
complications that we face.
It's equally important
to understand
the history of energy if you
consider that Americans have
not always desired
new sources of energy,
but rather a lot of work has
gone into creating demand
and teaching people
how to harness power
from different energy sources.
So without further ado, help
me welcome Chris to Google.
CHRISTOPHER F. JONES:
Well thank you.
I really appreciate
everyone making it here.
I know with the
World Cup on, there's
a lot of other distractions.
But it's an honor to be here.
It's great to be
back in the Bay Area.
I've lived here nine years of
my life at different times.
And so for me the Bay Area
feels a bit like a second home,
even as I am adjusting to
the new world of Arizona.
Never been a
Southwesterner before,
but I've found that's
an enjoyable place
to live as well.
So I'm going to talk
to you about the book
that I wrote that's pretty
newly off the shelves.
Came out in April.
And in the talk today
I'm going to give you
a little sense of
what's in the book.
And I also want to pull
out some of the arguments.
I know that probably not
everyone here is a historian.
So rather than going into
some of the full stories
about the past, I
want to pull out some
of the lessons about
energy transitions--
the dynamics of them that
are relevant to today.
And at the end
I'll link that past
to the present a little bit.
And I presume in some
of your questions
we'll have a chance to talk
about that topic in more depth.
So with that being
said, the book in itself
is what I think of as
very much being an origin
story of the roots of American
fossil fuel dependence.
And in the book, the
time period of it
covers the period
of 1820 to 1930.
This is a period where there's
a rising use of coal, oil,
and electricity in America.
And I study it in the
mid-Atlantic region,
which I'll say a
little bit more about.
And also a key
aspect of the book
is the focus on the transport
infrastructure system.
So the name "Route
to Power," routes
is referring to the transport
infrastructure systems,
but also trying to pun
on the idea of the roots
and origins of this story.
So this is a story very much
with a geographic component,
not a geographic
component that's
here, but is very much linked
to the Eastern seaboard
and the mid-Atlantic region.
And the reason I'm situating
the study in the mid-Atlantic
is this is the first
place that Americans
began to use fossil
fuel energy intensively.
It was in Pennsylvania,
New York, New Jersey,
that Americans first started
harnessing these technologies
and using them in
different ways.
And in many ways, the patterns
that were developed there
helped spread to the
rest of the nation.
So if we want to grapple
with really how, when,
where, and why Americans began
to use fossil fuel energy,
the mid-Atlantic is
the place to look.
The second big aspect of
this book that I'm looking at
is arguing that energy transport
infrastructure systems have
been an under-appreciated
driver of energy transitions.
So in the book, I'm looking at
things like coal canals, oil
pipelines, and electricity
transmission wires.
Not what we always think of
as the most sexy or glamorous
technologies, but
I argue they've
actually had a really
significant influence
in shaping the timing and the
contours of different energy
transitions.
And so I'm going to
tell you a bit more
about these technologies--
how they were built,
and why they were important.
Now in one sense, this is
a book about three energy
transitions-- coal,
oil, and electricity.
But I'm arguing
these actually also
could be thought of as
part of one big shift--
a shift from the organic to
the mineral energy regime.
And if we want to think
really big and broadly
about energy history
and what matters,
myself and a number of
other energy historians
have distinguished between
what could be considered
an organic energy regime
before this period of my study
starting, and a mineral energy
regime happening afterwards.
And why this is
important is it's
at one level, a story about
different energy sources,
but it's also a story about
different possibilities
for economic growth.
And so an organic
energy regime refers
to a world in which
energy is captured
through flows of solar energy.
It's mainly captured
actually through food.
Throughout world
history, food has
been the single most
important source of energy.
It's either been
what people have
eaten to power
their own muscles,
or it's been what
people have fed
to animals to use
that animal labor.
A number of people have
done studies to look at,
in fact, how much
energy comes from food.
And in most societies
throughout world history
spend 98% percent or more.
Things like wind
power, or falling water
have provided only
small amounts.
So in an organic
energy regime, food
is really important
to how you get energy.
Well, how do you get food?
Well you need to
land to grow food.
And so a consequence of
the organic energy regime
is that the amount of
land you have actually
limits the amount of energy
that you can possibly have.
And in densely populated
worlds, this actually
starts to produce
finite limits to growth.
The use of fossil
fuels is important
not simply because it's a
new type of energy source,
but because they shift this
relationship between land
and energy.
Fossil fuels provide
essentially free energy
that's separate of land.
And it allows the start of ever
increasing patterns of growth.
And so the rise of an
industrial economy, big cities,
I argue throughout the book
is actually intimately linked
to changing energy practices.
So these aren't just sort
of what energy source
you put in your stove
or that you use.
These are social
choices that affect
large patterns of development.
And we can think
about this, but if you
want to think about
world history,
this is actually the second
great energy transition.
The first and
arguably, but actually
the most important things humans
ever did was to start to farm.
The Neolithic Revolution
starting about 10,000 years ago
and the start of
settled agriculture
was hugely important.
Before that, humans mostly
did hunting and gathering.
Once you start to
farm, you can get
a lot more energy
per unit of land.
This means for the first
time, dense enough populations
to form city starts to happen.
Once you get cities, you start
to see the rise of writing.
You start to see the
rise of legal systems
and a whole host of
things that people broadly
consider civilization.
So if we want to think
about the rise of sort
of human settlements
and what we think,
it's actually linked to
an energy revolution.
This book is really
about the second of them.
The shift then from
farming to fossil fuels
as the main energy source is a
dramatic expansion in the size
that cities reach, in the
types of industrial economies
that developed, and the sort of
patterns of growth that emerge.
So if you want to
think a really big,
and I like to think really big.
Part of what's nice
about being a historian
is you can look at
big changes over time.
What I'm looking at in
this book is the second
of this really big set
of energy revolutions.
And part of the point of
looking at it this way again
is to see energy
not just as sort of,
do you go from wood to coal?
But how do energy
changes affect society?
And for the US, this is
sort of very much the shift
from being a kind of mercantile
outpost in the global economy
at the beginning of the period
to the industrial center.
So this is obviously
a big story.
So what am I adding
to it in particular?
Well I'm providing
a lot of detail
and identifying
points of contingency
and what people
have often described
as this very broad and sort
of clear set of changes.
And so I do things in the book.
I start quantifying the
capacities and the limitations
of different types
of energy sources.
And I look at the overlap of
these different energy regimes.
So I think if you have time to
start delving into the book,
you'll see yes, there's
this big pattern,
but there's also a lot of really
interesting detail about how
it gets there.
Lot of detail that
I unfortunately
won't have time to cover today.
But you'll have access to
the book to look at it later.
So I'm kind of offering
a new explanation
of why this ended up happening.
So that's a bit of an
overview about what's
in the book itself.
Let me try and extract
a few of the points
now and talk to you about
dynamics of energy transitions.
I'm going to do three points.
One about why transport
matters, a second about building
demand, and a third about energy
transitions and inequality.
So the first point, the
biggest point for my book,
transport matters.
OK.
Heard it.
You can go home now.
No.
Let's go into this a
little more about why
it ends up that
transport matters.
And it matters at a couple
of different levels.
There's of course the
most obvious thing to say,
which is that transport systems
are needed to move energy
from point A to point B. And
this is a reality of geography.
So here's a map.
Here we're looking
a Pennsylvania here.
And I look at three
different supplies of energy.
So this is the
anthracite coal region.
This was the first source
of fossil fuel Americans
used intensively.
Oil started in
Pennsylvania as well.
Edwin Drake in 1859 strikes oil
in Titusville, Pennsylvania.
And before we end up with
Texas and California being
the big oil states is
actually Pennsylvania.
And I also look at
hydroelectricity
along the lower
Susquehanna River.
What's common in all
three of these examples
is where these energy sources
are not where people live.
And if you look at pretty much
all the major sources of energy
that are used around
the globe today,
in most cases where energy is
found is not where people live.
So we can certainly say there's
a kind of obvious but perhaps
banal point, which is
that getting this energy
requires some type of
infrastructure from point A
to point B. Here's the paths
of the various canals built
in eastern Pennsylvania
connecting these coal
fields to the eastern
seaboard, particularly
to New York City
and Philadelphia.
And this type of infrastructure
was really necessary,
because moving energy without
infrastructure advantages
is extremely cost prohibitive.
So for example, here's one
of the historical documents
I found.
And this is obviously too
much to parse right away.
The big point of this chart
is people doing calculations
in 1821, showing that
moving coal over land
costs huge amounts of money,
but that building canals would
drop the cost enormously.
And they actually even
found it is cheaper
to import coal 3,000 miles from
Britain before the building
of canals than it was to ship
it 100 miles over the land.
And so one of the things
to remember about energy
is it's used in huge amounts.
And if we're talking about
coal, oil, or electricity,
we're talking about a
very bulky or heavy--
and in the case of electricity--
very ephemeral substance,
that you can't just move
it in the quantities needed
to be necessary without
investing in infrastructure.
OK.
So at one level, I
think anyone would
agree you need
infrastructure to move it.
I don't think that's
particularly innovative here.
So let me say a little more
about why I think actually
transport systems have been even
more important than typically
understood.
Well one factor is that building
these infrastructure systems
actually at the time turned
out to be as challenging and as
expensive as building this
sort of technology needed
to get coal out of the ground,
or oil out of the ground,
or build electric generators.
Turns out these
are fairly complex
technologies, which under
the conditions of the time
were incredibly
difficult to build.
This is sledding pipes for
the world's first pipeline
that was built in 1879.
This involved huge
amounts of physical labor,
but also manufacturing
capacity to build the pipes,
and to test these,
and to make them work.
So at one level, building
these infrastructures
was actually quite a broad and
difficult set of challenges
that people had to face.
They also had very high costs.
And this high cost to them--
I'm going to return to
in the next section-- is
actually really important.
What happens is people
start to experience
some costs in infrastructure.
And those people who
build these systems
realize that we can't
just build these systems
and expect demand to occur.
We need to drive
demand so that we
use these systems at
their maximum capacity.
They have heavy
financial incentives.
So when we start
looking at who's
encouraging the use
of new energy sources,
we actually see that
it's often the directors
of these infrastructure
projects,
because they put up so much
money in investing them.
What does end up
happening, as I show
in each of the case studies
throughout the book,
is once these infrastructures
are put in place,
it facilitates an enormous
expansion of energy flows.
And so this is my attempt--
you remember in high school
textbooks, when you
saw sort of battle maps
with armies moving
around by arrows?
This is my attempt to do
the same thing with coal.
And these arrows are
weighted by the amount
of coal being shipped.
The point is, once
these systems start
to get built, enormous
quantities of coal
start flowing along them,
and oil and electricity
in the same way, to create
a major transfer of energy
from one place to another.
OK.
So this is part of the reason
why transport matters, and I'm
going to get at
it a little more.
I want to do this
also by linking it
to a second real key feature
of energy transitions.
And of course, this morning
I made a terrible mistake
in doing this.
And I wrote that
demand drives supply,
which is what we expect.
And it's actually the
entire opposite of this.
What I found in energy
studies in all of these cases
is that people found
it was actually
quite easy to produce coal,
oil, or electricity in amounts
greater than people
would buy them.
And so it was actually the
having of large amounts
of energy that encouraged
a whole bunch of people
to start looking and
creating new markets.
The idea of the gushing
oil well captures
this idea, that you
could look for oil,
suddenly find it
in huge amounts,
and you had no one to
actually sell it to.
So why is this case?
Well part of it is that new
energy sources for consumers
were considered expensive,
unreliable, and hard to use.
Right?
Remember, if we talk about
1820, the first time coal
starts to be used.
Or 1859 when Drake
first discovered oil,
or when Thomas Edison
invented electric light bulbs.
It's not that people hadn't
been heating their homes,
or that they didn't
have light before this.
They did.
They had options.
They used candles,
they used wood.
They had options.
And so they had to be convinced
that their current way of doing
things didn't make
sense anymore.
This of course,
this conversation
about convincing
people who are used
to doing things one way
is something, I'm sure,
is quite familiar in this room.
Another key factor is
that most energy systems
require consumers
to make investments
in secondary
technologies to use them.
Right?
So you don't use
electricity directly.
You plug devices into the
wall to use electricity.
If you want to use coal,
you need a stove to do it.
If you want to use
oil-- and part of what
I'm saying oil is
lighting-- is actually
the first several
decades of oil's main use
was actually for
illumination, not for power.
The first major product
for petroleum with kerosene
as kerosene lamps,
not the motors
or the automobiles
that we think of today.
A third factor in
making these hard to use
was that people had to
develop new techniques.
Actually using a kerosene lamp
requires filling the lamp.
It requires tending the wick.
It requires sort of knowing
how much air to let in.
When you clean it.
When you don't.
And so the whole
point of this is
that for people to adopt
new energy sources,
there were a lot of techniques
they had to go through.
In some cases this was
made much more challenging
by the actual material
characteristics of the energy
sources.
So anthracite coal-- for people
who are not coal experts-- when
I say anthracite, coal is
divided into several categories
based on how much carbon it has.
Anthracite coal has
lots of carbon in it.
Bituminous less, semi-bituminous
even less, and lignite lower.
When you hear people
talking about brown coal,
it's the lignite
or semi-bituminous.
What matters about
anthracite is,
high carbon content means it
burns very hot, very clean.
But it's hard to light.
You can't just sort of throw it
on a fire and have it ignite.
You actually have to arrange a
fire in a very particular way.
And so this challenge leads
several early Americans
of many associated
with the coal companies
to actually start trying to
convince people and teach them
how to use it.
So here, one of
the sources I found
was a directory for servants.
This is like, telling people
how do you clean brass knobs?
How do you get stains out
of your master's nice shirt?
How do you maintain a house?
And one of the key
things they added
was a long section on
how to actually light
a fire using anthracite.
And one of the
quotations from it
is that very few
servants at first
understand the method of
kindling and continuing
a fire of Lehigh coal.
Many will never learn.
And many more from
erroneous instructions,
whilst they think
they understand it,
make but a bungling
piece of work of it.
Capturing the idea.
This is lighting a fire,
which we kind of think
is a really easy thing, but
actually is more complex.
And so one of the aspects
of energy transitions
in the past that we
forget to look at
is how challenging it was
for some of these new sources
to get adopted.
But as I mentioned
briefly before
in the section on
transport technologies,
those who invested huge amounts
of money in building systems
to move transport couldn't
let sluggish market demand
let their infrastructure
investments go to waste.
So paraphrasing the
Field of Dreams idea
of "if you build it, they will
come," for these boosters,
that was not the case at all.
It was, if you build it,
you must make them come.
You must actively take
the effort to do it.
So Josiah White was the pioneer
of one of the first canals.
I call him a booster
extraordinaire,
because he did
sort of everything
he could to encourage the
use of anthracite coal.
And what he did kind of
symbolizes and stands
in for what lots of
other people did.
So he would write testimonials
to newspapers about how good
anthracite coal was.
He would give promising
samples to companies that said,
we'll try using coal in our
blacksmith shop, for example.
And he said, alright, if you
will make an experiment of it,
I'll give you a
certain amount free.
And if you like it, then
you'll come back for it.
Early drug pusher model for the
adoption of new energy sources.
He actually-- and it's kind
of hard to know exactly how
well this went over
at home-- but he
insisted that his wife keep a
fire burning with anthracite
at all times in their home,
so that people could come over
and actually see it.
So it's steps like
this-- kind of humble,
seem like sort of
small things-- but are
part of what many,
many people at the time
were doing to overcome
these great challenges.
We can see it in oil.
We can see it in
electricity as well.
Here's a 1922 advertisement
from the Westinghouse
Company about an electric stove.
And here's a picture
of the stove.
What's interesting is this
is a woman in her sort
of nice, upper middle
class home, is speaking.
And she's talking about how she
has an invisible servant that
saves me money, time, and work.
It's dependable, it's capable,
and it requires no supervision.
And it makes cooking a pleasure.
And it gives us better food
than we've ever had before.
Note she's saying that
while her own servant is
in the background here,
who clearly does require
supervision, clearly is
not dependable or capable,
and is sort of
making this contrast.
But the point would be,
one could find thousands
of advertisements from this
period of convincing people
not just that this
was functional,
but this was part
of modern life.
It was part of what
it meant to be better.
And so this combination of
pushing demand and the fact
that transport boosters
were often driving this
leads me to
introduce in the book
an idea that runs
through it, which
is the idea of landscapes
of intensification.
And this is kind of how I
pull this idea together.
And what I'm really
interested in
is how over time, this set
of positive feedback loops
develops between the
start of the fact
that energy is found in
rural and remote areas,
the fact that building these
canals, pipelines, and wires
is very expensive,
linked to the fact
that demand has to be
created, helped drive the fact
that owners of transport
systems are therefore
incentivized to be big
boosters to drive energy,
over time we do
see that consumers
start to increase their demand.
And then there's one more
really key step here,
which is the fact that
infrastructure operates
with economies of
scale, quite often.
And so canals, pipelines,
and wires are built,
but then they are frequently
expanded, they're widened,
they're deepened.
And they begin to be able to
carry greater amounts of energy
at lower per unit cost.
And so these expansion
of transport networks
play an important
role, because they
end up lowering the
prices to consumers, which
helps further drive
demand, and sustain
the logic of energy transitions.
And so this set of features
kind of rolling on themselves
is, I think, part of what
helps explain not just
why the energy transitions
begin, but why they keep going.
And so it essentially
becomes a set
of what we can think about as
synergistic feedback loops.
So in 1820, when the
first canal is opened,
the estimates are, they
cost about $5 per ton.
And the price of coal is about
$8.40 for a wholesale ton.
By 1825, a couple more
canals are opened.
The per unit prices go down.
By 10 years later, canals are
being widened and deepened.
And by 1850, the canals
have much bigger capacity.
This ends up lowering
the shipment cost.
And these savings
are pretty much
entirely passed onto consumers,
so that the price of coal
is constantly getting
lower and lower.
And at the same time,
this is driving really
a quite remarkable set of
increases in the amount of coal
that's being shipped, such that
by the outbreak of the Civil
War, already 8
million tons of coal
are being shipped in this area,
which is a huge increase even
from the decade
before, let alone
the period a few decades before.
So thinking about the fact
that demand has to be created,
that transport boosters do it,
and that these systems help
sustain this loop,
is why I think
about this idea of
landscapes of intensification
and how transport
starts to matter
at perhaps a less
initially obvious level.
OK.
A third point that
I want to bring up
is that energy transitions
tend to be unequal as well.
And I'll give you a
couple examples of this,
and particularly how
transport systems shape this.
And part of the reason I'll
mention this a little later,
there's an obviously
a great need
to push energy transitions
to renewable alternatives
in this country and
across the world.
But as I'll show, there are
design decisions and choices
that affect who benefits
from this and who does not.
And I think that though it's
important to act quickly,
we can also think about
questions of equality
to make it a more
egalitarian transition that
will benefit more people.
So here's a chart of how
many people have access
to electricity in 1933.
And we can see
actually the US is
way below many of the
European nations in terms
of the percentage of the
population with access,
under 70%.
So at one level, we can just
see throughout the history
of energy transition,
some people get access
to the cheap energy,
and some people do not.
And I think this is probably
a familiar conversation here,
thinking about where globally
do people have access
to different types of internet
services, different types
of wireless networks, et cetera.
A similar dynamic
is going on here.
There's also ways in which
transport infrastructure shapes
this very directly.
And one of the things I
talk about in the book
is that the production
of energy very often
comes at tremendous
environmental cost.
So this is 10 years
after the oil boom
starts in western Pennsylvania.
And as a sort of symbol of
what the deforestation, mud
and derrick-filled
areas look like.
What is significant,
I think, about this
is the fact that the consumers
of oil are not living here.
So there is great
environmental harm,
but not at the places where
consumers end up living.
And part of what's going
on, I'm arguing in the book,
is that the building
of transport systems
creates a physical
dissociation between those
who produce energy
and have to live
with the cost of
that production,
and those consumers who
use it and benefit from it.
And there are, of
course, a wide range
of reasons we could think
about for why Americans
throughout their
history have not
argued for strong
environmental laws
to protect areas where
energy is produced.
But one thing I
want to argue is we
need to keep in mind
the fact that there
was very little incentive for
the people who are actually
using energy during this period
to demand the types of changes
that would protect these areas.
And it's similar today.
I mean, the eastern seaboard
gets plenty of its coal power
from coal mines
in West Virginia,
but people in Manhattan
aren't dealing
with mountaintop removal.
And similarly, you
can find stories
very much in our own
current era where
energy is produced separately
from where it's used.
It means that environmental
harms are concentrated
in places where users
are not located.
There also are
material differences
in transport infrastructure
systems that help explain this.
And so one of the features
of a canal-- and by the way,
I should say, some
people get confused.
A coal canal is not separate
from a regular canal.
I should say, it's a
canal designed primarily
built to carry coal.
And I refer to these as coal
canals, because over 80%
of their traffic was coal.
But basically, canals are
sophisticated technologies,
but largely you can think about
them as big ditches or rivers
that you can go up and down.
And there's no technological
obstacle to drawing off points
in between the sort of start
and the end of a canal.
And one of the things we
see that happens in the coal
regions is actually
between where
coal is mined in
Philadelphia and New York
at the end of the
canals, there's
actually quite substantial
industrial buildup
along the canals.
Lot of towns along them benefit,
develop quite profitable
industries, and the distribution
of benefits gets spread out.
And this is partially
because on a canal,
you can pull over a boat at
any point and deliver coal.
Pipelines-- and here's a picture
of a pipeline over here--
did not actually have places
where oil could be drawn off
in between the point
where it started
and the point where it ends.
So if you live next
to a pipeline, that
didn't mean you're getting
cheaper access to oil,
it simply meant if the pipeline
burst-- and pipelines did
burst-- that your
property would be damaged,
but it wasn't going to give
you cheaper access to oil.
So there can be very
specific design features
that shape whether
more people benefit.
So now you may say,
alright, renewable energy.
We're talking about electricity
transmission lines maybe.
And electricity
transmission lines
can send energy multiple
places, but they
need transforming stations
to step power up and down.
And often these transformers
are quite expensive.
So if say, we build a giant wind
farm in the Great Plain area,
it's not guaranteed that
towns nearby will actually
get that energy, unless
some of the design decisions
are made to make that happen.
So transport
systems can not only
shape where and when these
energy transitions happen,
but can also augment who
ends up benefiting from them.
Alright.
I started doing
this a little bit
linking the past and
present in my talk,
but let me just mention three
quick points about this.
And I imagine in our discussion,
we'll talk about it more.
So one point in this study
for the present is, of course,
transport infrastructure
for renewable energy
would be a good idea.
As many people note,
the places where
the sun shines the brightest--
and that's what this map is--
are not always the places
where population ends up
being clustered.
And the same thing is certainly
true for where the wind ends up
blowing the hardest.
That these are not the locations
where people end up living.
So if we want to expand
renewable energy production,
some level of new
transmission infrastructure
will be necessary, and it's
important to think about.
Google actually
has been involved
in a potentially
interesting project.
I don't know who's heard
about the Atlantic--
have you heard of it?
Who's heard of the
Atlantic Wind Connection
that Google's involved in?
OK.
Only a couple people.
Google is actually one
of the major sponsors
of this the idea
of a major-- this
is the Eastern seaboard between
Virginia and New Jersey.
And Google, it's
proposed Google's got
about a 37% stake in the
project with a couple
other partners, a $5 billion
offshore transmission
line that would have
put offshore wind farms
and transmit this power
on the Eastern seaboard.
So that's actually an
interesting project
that hopefully will go through.
But some new types of
infrastructure like this
are absolutely going
to be necessary.
A second point that I
look at is to realize
that energy transitions
take decades,
and they require boosters,
and they particularly
require boosters to be patient.
So a couple lessons, I would
say, for renewable energy
advocates are first--
we need to remember
that these transitions require
active efforts to build demand,
to work with consumers, to
solve technical problems,
to promote alternative fuels.
And partly what I'm trying
to do in the book is also,
some people say, well if
renewable energy requires
people to be
convinced, then it's
simply not as good as
coal, oil, and electricity.
And I would say no.
In fact, in their early stages,
coal, oil, and electricity
needed this absolutely as much.
So the fact that for
renewable energy projects
this is necessary,
shouldn't be a surprise.
I think it's also important
to set realistic expectations
for timelines.
These transitions take decades.
And in this sense it's a very
non-Silicon Valley project.
Right?
This is not a place where
transitions and scales
of decades are often discussed.
But I would argue the
computer industry is often
a bad analogy for the patterns
of energy transitions,
because disruption can happen,
but on a longer time scale.
And so there's also a
really important aspect
of pursuing long term
strategies in this
that I think a look at
historical energy transitions
provides.
And part of why I mention this
is that at different times,
there's been huge hope
that renewables are just
around the corner, or are about
to make that breakthrough.
And when they don't
seem to immediately,
people get really discouraged.
But if you look at
the history of energy,
you can find similar patterns
of delay with the fossil fuels.
And so it's not necessarily
that they are that incredibly
different in this capacity.
And the final point I'll
mention is to just pay attention
to questions of equality.
And one way we can
do this is, again,
thinking about whether
production and consumption
happen in different places.
So now, as I said
at the beginning,
I've moved to Arizona.
We have lots of deserts.
There are plenty of
proposals to just cover them
all over with
different solar panels.
Here's an installation
in the Mojave Desert.
It turns out deserts aren't
completely empty places.
There are species
that live there.
There are people
who live there who
find these landscapes
to be valuable.
And one could make a
cost-benefit analysis
to say that the benefits
of the renewable energy
are really high, but what
this does is actually
risk recreating some of
the patterns of inequality
from older transport
infrastructure systems,
where those who live
where energy is produced
pay the costs, while those
who benefit live elsewhere.
And a lot of people will
say, hey, why should we
cover over the Arizona
desert so that people in LA
can have air conditioning?
Right?
Shouldn't people in
LA be experiencing
some of the cost of
that energy production
and not just shifting
it on to other people?
And so this suggests to
me that actually there
are different models of
solar energy production.
There are the
utility scale farms.
But there's also
a lot of potential
for rooftops or for
commercial solar development.
And there certainly is
an equality argument
to be made to say,
we should at least
be using rooftops
in urban areas where
this is being used before
moving on to deserts.
I mean, maybe all of
LA gets plastered,
and we still need more energy.
Then maybe there's
reasonable discussions
to be had about what areas
should be used to produce this.
But until those types
of steps happen,
it's actually worth thinking
about why other regions should
be having their
landscapes transformed
to suit the benefits
of distance consumers.
So these are some thoughts
on energy transitions
past and present.
I appreciate you
being here, and I'm
happy to take some
questions about it.
AUDIENCE: A question.
Historically, was it
the same companies
who were doing production
and transport of the energy?
And how do you think that will
work with renewable energy?
CHRISTOPHER F.
JONES: Good question.
So it depends on the industry
actually, and it's not similar
in this capacity.
So in coal, different
companies mined.
And then different
companies shipped.
And then even different
companies sold.
So it was a different
division structure.
In oil, different companies
transported from drilled--
and actually what
I didn't get into,
but this goes into
the book-- transport,
and these are the early
pipelines in 1884.
These are mostly pipelines
built by John D. Rockefeller.
And they are crucial to his
monopoly over the oil industry
at this time.
So oil is first found in 1859.
By 1879, John D.
Rockefeller controls
90% of the American
oil industry.
He achieves this monopoly
position despite the fact
that his company
does not produce oil.
What it does is it refines
the oil from crude oil
into the kerosene that
people are buying.
And that's how he controls
how much gets to market.
He also ends up
building pipelines
to control the
transport of it as well,
and control it at that stage.
But he does not
vertically integrate.
He does not choose to actually
own the production of oil
until a much later period.
And then he never had
the same level of control
as he ends up doing.
In the case of electricity
that I'm looking at,
it usually is the case that
the same company ends up
owning the production.
So actually there's shifts
between the industries
in terms of that dynamic.
I do know today,
there are companies
pursuing transmission
wires that are
separate from owning the
energy production facilities.
And so the two are not
necessarily always linked.
AUDIENCE: This isn't
energy exactly,
but as you're
going through this,
and as I was reading the
introduction to your book,
it seemed there are an
awful lot of parallels
between the flow of energy
and the flow of communication,
because we have the
telegraph, and there
are more efficient methods of
communication than the internet
now.
Do you have any comment
to make on that?
And I'd be interested to hear.
CHRISTOPHER F. JONES:
They are a great topic.
And in fact, when I began
this project-- I don't even
want to admit how
long ago it was-- I
was thinking about
technological transitions
is what I wanted to study.
And the two topics that
stood out to me most
were these energy
transitions, but also
the communication
technology angle
of things, where you
can look at telegraph,
radio, telephone, other
types of networks going on.
So I think there absolutely
are some parallel stories here.
I would say, you
end up probably even
in some senses with a
little more monopoly, even
in the communication
infrastructure
sometimes than you do, even
with the energy infrastructures
that you have here.
But you also get similar
historical moments
that a lot of this
development occurs.
The communication
sometimes proceeds
some of these technologies,
but telegraph is very linked
to the spread of the
railroad as well.
So in short, I guess I would
say you could definitely
make some really interesting
parallels, certainly
about the role of
infrastructure in it.
And I think you would absolutely
find a lot of overlap.
The industry conditions do end
up being a point of difference,
though, that I would
end up seeing on that.
So good question.
I'll think for a minute
whether I have something
more for you in just a second.
I'll move to the next perhaps.
AUDIENCE: I didn't hear any
mention of government in this.
CHRISTOPHER F. JONES: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And specifically,
I'm thinking of my parents
growing up in the Midwest
before the Rural Electric
Administration.
Could you talk about
government's role
and how you see that in
the past and going forward?
CHRISTOPHER F. JONES: There's a
really important shifting role
of government in this story
throughout the time period.
And it affects each of these
stories in different ways.
The Rural Electrification
Administration
becomes remarkably
important for spreading
American electrification
much further.
This happens in 1935, a
little after my story ends.
It turns out state government is
more important to these stories
often than federal
government at the time.
The spread of the
federal government
as having the policies
that influence
industrial development
really starts
to come more in the 20th century
than it does in the 19th.
So what I argue is
that the state ends up
playing a really important
role in structuring
what can be done.
So what do state governments
do that make a difference?
Well, a., they give
corporate privileges.
And this is something we don't
really think about today.
If you want to start
a company, and you
want a corporate charter,
you fill out a few forms.
You send a check somewhere.
And you get a corporate charter.
In the 19th century,
every corporate charter
was voted on by the
state legislature
to determine if that corporate
charter would be given.
So in order to even get the
type of corporate charter
that would help you raise
the money to do this,
you actually needed the
buy in of the state.
There were several times
that states either did
or did not tax energy,
and that influenced
the rate of growth of it.
Often, the States were
partners in helping
to drive energy demands.
So Pennsylvania for
example, in response
to people advocating for how the
state could help these energy
industries, they gave
special corporate charters
to companies that would
make iron using the coal.
And so they made it easier for
certain groups to play out.
This map of pipelines looks
this way a little bit.
The first pipeline here,
the Tidewater Pipeline
was the world's first
long distance pipeline.
It was not built by Rockefeller.
It was built by a group of
independent oilmen hoping
to overturn his monopoly.
They had tried and failed--
because Rockefeller
had a lot of control
in the government--
to get what was called
a Free Pipeline bill.
A bill that would give pipeline
companies eminent domain.
It never passed.
What you don't see in
the map is that this
is going through the
Allegheny Mountains.
It's that area where
I showed the earlier
slide of people
slugging pipelines.
They basically could
buy land breaks there,
because there wasn't much there.
But no one else could obtain
those same land rights.
So the reason why
Rockefeller was
able to build all
the other pipelines
was because he was
able to get laws
that helped him and not others.
So there's not one story of
how the states influenced
these developments.
But I think of it in general,
the state was absolutely
setting the terms
of the development,
helping these things
in certain ways,
hindering these
efforts in other ways,
benefiting certain
groups and not others.
But it generally was at
a state government level
during this time.
It was almost always on a
fairly ad hoc basis, not
part of any long
plan, but responding
to what seemed like crises
in any given moment.
So state plays a
very important role,
but one that is
hard to summarize,
because it showed up
in each of these cases
in quite different ways.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the booster approach,
and in the past, you
said that what was really
needed to catalyze the use
of these types of fuels
were the boosters.
But back then there wasn't
this cost challenge,
because it was affordable.
You just needed the
behavioral shift for people
to use that type of fuel.
In our age, where
renewable energy--
the barrier is the cost.
What do the boosters
need to do-- things like,
I as a consumer
can't say, I only
want to fuel my house
based on renewable energy.
I don't want coal-fired
power plants.
What do the boosters need
to do to inspire shifts now?
CHRISTOPHER F. JONES:
Well one thing I would say
is, we shouldn't quite
overstate how amazing the cost
advantage was.
It wasn't always right
at the beginning.
Part of the point
of-- it did eventually
become a significant
cost advantage--
but part of that required
paying off the infrastructure,
building enough so that you
got the economies of scale.
So one thing we should realize
is right away at the sort
original historical moment, it
wasn't absolutely overwhelming.
And also what partly was
another cost thing people had
to overcome was people
had to actually invest
in a secondary technology.
So one thing I
would just say is,
let's not say that they had
on overwhelming cost advantage
from the very
beginning that makes
it so different from
what's going on today.
What arguably was
actually the biggest thing
was unfamiliarity
with the technology.
How do you use it?
Do you trust it?
Is it safe?
Is it reliable?
And this is actually
what you hear
about people with solar panels.
Like, is it going to
be reliable on my roof?
If I put it on my
roof, is that gonna
give me roof problems
that do this.
Is the system going to crash?
You can find stories of
people putting in their solar,
it doesn't work as they expect.
And that turns off other people.
And so I would
actually say, there
is the-- I mean it very much
is a consumer behavior story--
but a lot of this
is unglamorous work.
We remember names
from the oil industry
like John D. Rockefeller.
We don't know the names of the
people who went door to door
and showed people how
to use a kerosene lamp.
But this actually was
part of what happened.
So I'd say one thing would
be to sort of celebrate
a little of the
mundane work of it.
That it's not simply Elon Musk,
whose technological insight
is going to transform this.
But it's actually going to
be some of those people who
are going door to
door convincing people
to make this happen.
So that's a little bit
of a thought on it.
AUDIENCE: With the
boosters that went into it,
it seems like there was a lot
of build up with companies that
were providing these
services and things,
to build up marketing
departments,
or PR customer service branches.
Did you see in
your research a lot
of the growth of that
in industry as well?
And was it happening sort
of alongside these changes?
CHRISTOPHER F.
JONES: Good question.
Yeah.
There is growth in
how this happens.
And it depends on
industry structure,
sort of back to the
earlier question.
So coal was sold by marketing
companies sometimes.
And what advertising
looked like in that day
was actually often
a little newspaper.
Not the sort of things
we would consider
to be very sophisticated
or sexy advertisements,
but were actually how word
got around about this.
But there were also
demonstrations.
Another aspect of this
is different parts
of society not associated with
the industry sometimes got
involved as well, because
they were boosters
for the state of Pennsylvania.
So in Philadelphia,
the Franklin Institute
was a group of mechanics,
scientists, artisans,
and they would actually do
experiments to figure out
the optimal way to
burn anthracite.
Or how to burn anthracite
in this different area.
And they were doing
this-- some of them
were involved with
the coal companies--
but there actually was
a sort of civic minded,
if we can make
anthracite work, we're
going to be doing a good thing
for our state and our country's
development.
So in this early
stage, actually, you
do get a little bit
of corporate buildup.
You actually have
other people ending up
being involved with it.
But certainly part of the
huge Standard Oil success
is marketing, a great
attention to building out
their marketing.
To some of the early
really careful gathering
of statistics.
So Standard Oil's one
the first companies
to create a real
statistical department
in the late 19th century.
And they start calculating
how much is being used.
How much market share
does our competitors have?
What's the price point
at which we can get this?
So one of the very early
companies to do this
is Standard Oil.
The electric utilities
are where you really
see the start of what we would
consider more the modern PR.
Both with the
advertisements that they
do, the customer service areas.
One of the utilities that I
look at in Baltimore- they
open stores where they
demonstrate all the appliances
and how they
actually use things.
And these stores
are partially places
where you can buy
things, but they're
very much places where you
can learn how to actually use
these new devices and see
them for the first time.
AUDIENCE: The graph on
electricity coverage in 1933
was intriguing.
With some western
European countries
being 100%, what was
the role of government,
cohesiveness society,
size of the country,
why the huge change between
Denmark and Austria,
for example?
CHRISTOPHER F. JONES:
Policy matters.
It's a big aspect of this.
So in the early years
of electrification,
much more so than
we see right now,
there was a huge
question as to whether it
was going to be public or
private managed utilities.
And even within the
US, lots of towns
have their own municipal
electric works.
And if you were
standing at 1910,
1915, it wasn't clear which
the direction was going to go.
Even more so in Europe.
So there's a lot more
publicly owned power
where both as sort
of policies, they
were required to serve
people, but there's also
sort of a democratically
accountable process for how
electrification
was going to go in.
That they are simply not
with a private utility.
Obviously geography
matters a bit here.
Canada's right next to the US.
And people did point
out it's harder
to wire a sort of geographically
dispersed country.
But as you know, within
concentrated countries
in Europe, there's
a big difference.
And so it's a
combination of policy,
and was it public or private
ownership of the plants
themselves which fed back into
the policies that governed it.
MALE SPEAKER: So thanks
so much for coming.
CHRISTOPHER F. JONES: Thank you.